[Music]
[Applause]
all right last year JJ Watt was listed
at 288 on the Cardinals roster all right
what does JJ Watt weigh now who would
like to go first Todd will start with
you
I was just texting someone and I did not
hear the question how much did JJ Watt
currently weigh he weighs two
58. 258.
all right see no Connor what's JJ Watt
why right now let's say 265. all right
Marvin
let's say
268.68 Paulie
262.
I'm gonna go 267. and we're all flirting
right yeah we are I think he's dropped
to 20. spring in JJ Watt three-time NFL
defensive player of the year now going
to be working for CBS Sports in the
studio JJ how much do you weigh right
now
well first of all um I listed weight was
a little high last year I actually
played it about 281 282.
um I currently weigh 278.
278.
yeah you've let yourself go I know it's
a disaster it's it's just a disaster
um no it is interesting it's very
interesting the whole dynamic of how it
all goes from a nutrition and a lifting
working out standpoint when you're done
um I certainly eat a lot less
than I did when I was playing
um I still work out about four days a
week but a whole lot less running and
cardio a lot more vanity and cosmetic
lifts but uh okay but I still there's
still some habits that are hard to break
I still squat um I still do a lot of a
lot of lifts I used to but I'm down
about three pounds I I agree with you
guys it does feel and look like I've
lost a little bit more but the scale
still says 278. how close were you to
playing for the Packers
oh wow you're really going in it right
away
um it's a story for another day but
um
it would have been awesome well why why
for another day
um I have to get more I have to get more
information uh about it before I really
talk about it more but
um it would have been cool yeah I
thought that that seemed like able to go
back home and uh that it was going to be
a big deal to be able to do that or at
least try to do that so yeah I wasn't
yeah it wasn't really an option that's
all I'll say okay uh when did you uh get
interest from CBS to join them as a
studio host
um
that's a great question I mean we kind
of talked about stuff like this for the
last few years trying to see what
discussed what I would do when I was
done uh the biggest thing for me and the
thing I'm most excited about is
obviously
I said early in my career I didn't want
to do any of this stuff and then as I
got towards the end of my career I
realized how much I love the game and I
realized how much I want to be around it
I can't be away from it
um but I also want to be around my son I
also want to spend time with my family
and I didn't want to retire and
immediately hop into a 20 plus week job
so CBS has been incredible they're gonna
they're gonna let me come in and out
this fall spend some time with my son
come in do some things and then be a
part of the group so they've been great
if uh when your son gets ready to pick a
sport let's say he wants to pick a sport
which one since your wife soccer player
you of course playing football
where would you uh where would you steer
your son to
I mean did you see that contract and
Bape got offered
he's kicking a soccer ball as we speak
yeah and he's in training right now
would you steer him towards soccer
um I mean it's it it's I he's huge man I
mean he's a big big boy like I yeah sure
I would like him I think soccer would be
great but the reality is I think he's uh
I just you just look at him and he's I
think he's going to be a football player
but uh I I like I mean soccer is the
worldwide sport you can do so many
different things with it I think it's
very beneficial I've always said for
kids to play multiple Sports so he's
definitely going to play both growing up
um but I'm I'm not one of those guys
that's like I don't want my son to play
football if he wants to play football I
wanted to play football let's guess how
much JJ wants son weighs how old is how
old's your son he's nine months nine
months old Paulie yeah I got some info
inside information he was 18 pounds at
Birth so yeah
I got the announcement he was not 18.
I'm gonna go he's uh nine months
it's like 30 pounds
30 pounds Todd 24 7. all right oh
Seaton
202 and a half Marvin
28.
he's 23 he's 23 pounds right now at nine
months see um I haven't he hasn't been
weighed since the six months so I it
would be great if there was like a
commercial break or I could go in and
weigh him right now but I would guess
he's probably right around 25 pound Mark
right now okay what percentile
is is every time we go in she doesn't
even show us the charts she's just like
he's the top yeah
and once again you do not uh say you're
babysitting you don't babysit your own
child
no just want to make sure that well
people do that
and like the phrasing of oh what are you
doing today oh I gotta babysit my uh my
child
so just make sure that's terrible yes
that's terrible you're not babysitting
no no I'm taking care of my son well
where is he now
he uh I was I I am on morning duty today
my wife and I switched off every day who
wakes up with him
um but she was very kind to wake up so
that I could do this and he wasn't gonna
okay uh now I know a lot of times when
players go into the booth or they go in
as an analyst then people will say well
can you be critical uh you know are you
going to be able to offer you know what
opinions what insights like what will be
your approach in how as a former player
you handle the current players
yeah I'm I'm not shy in saying that I'm
not going to be the crazy critical guy
doing hot takes left and right because
I've been on the other side of that and
I know what it's like when the person in
the booth or the person analyzing it
doesn't know your exact job on that play
and doesn't know exactly what your
responsibility was so I'm not going to
be the guy popping off the handle saying
why was this guy in posting I post
safety coverage when he was supposed to
be covering the flat you know that's not
going to be me but I am going to offer a
bunch of insights and things that I have
learned over the years that I don't
think the general public uh hears a ton
of about I mean I think that there's a
lot of really interesting things that
you can learn and things that people
hear from snap counts to you know pre
pre play checks and things that guys are
doing I mean we hear all these things
like the omahas and like Patrick Mahomes
comes up to line he's saying all this
stuff
I've had 12 years of knowing exactly
what all that stuff means and I think
I'm not going to give away their secrets
but I do think the fans wonder what that
means I do think you know when you bring
a guy in motion and fans are wondering
why why are we doing this those are the
types of things that I can I can help
with uh and then also if a guy is
struggling if a guy's going through a
tough stretch maybe maybe it's a guy
that's normally a 15 20 sack guy and
he's not kicked to the quarterback
lately I can explain and point out why
that's happening whether it's double
teams whether it's chips whether it's
you see an extra attention Etc talking
to JJ Watt and uh he'll be working with
CBS as a studio analyst coming up this
fall
um I was also wondering about this when
you don't have to name names but a
quarterback who had a tell
when you're playing against them you
knew this
did you have how many of those
quarterbacks do you think that you
encountered
uh I mean everybody has something it
just depends on how useful it actually
is I mean there's some guys that give
away their snap count where you can tell
okay this one's going to be on one this
one's going to be on two there's some
guys how do you give away the snap count
so there's certain there's different
things like when a guy walks up to the
line of scrimmage a lot of times I mean
it's it's funny how simple this game can
be at times like there's you got to get
11 guys on the same page so a lot of
times you got to remind the offensive
lineman what the snap count is as you're
walking up to the line because there's
so many things going on through your
head they already forgot by the time
they get up there so a guy will say
something real simple it could literally
be just white white like as he's walking
around trying to do it nonchalantly but
if he says white white that means it's
on one if he says black black that means
it's on two little stuff like that
um and the even better than that like
this this is the great stuff even better
than that like we're football players
we're not the smartest people on the
planet after he says that the offensive
lineman will still have to remind each
other with the white white yet by white
and it's like you're getting triple
confirmation at the line of scrimmage
that it's on one
um and then I'm also a dumb football
player myself so I'm still jumping off
sides at times I know like like I'm
sitting over here like these idiots they
don't even know the snap count like they
can't remember it and then here I am
jumping off sides like a real
um then there's other bigger tells like
there's some quarterbacks in the shotgun
that they lift one heel up a little bit
if it's going to be a run play and they
put that heel down on the ground if it's
going to be a pass place so they can
drop back like there's there's little
things
um under Center some quarterbacks will
bend their knee a little bit more if
they're gonna drop and hand off the ball
to the right they're gonna hand it off
to the left so like there's a whole
bunch of little things like that that
are really fun and I love those are the
things my brother and I talked the most
about but also you're reading the tackle
who's in front of you I'm guessing for
body language as well
yeah yeah I mean you you can see a ton
of different things there
um a lot of times you know one of the
most basic ones is pass versus run a
guy's foot will be way back in the
stance if it's fast it'll be up forward
if it's a run
um I mean you have the old school one
that doesn't really work anymore because
everybody wears gloves but like the
White Knuckles leaning forward in a run
you know lean them back on a pass
um an interesting thing that I always
tell young guys with tackles with any
offensive lineman they're outside knee
always moves first
um it's just it's just a little thing
but it's always the first thing to move
so whenever you're keying it get off for
an offensive lineman you keep their
little outside knee if you're not a guy
that likes to look at the ball
um all little stuff like that that's
stuff you gain over there and it's good
stuff we had Steve Young on last week
and he said that today's game you've got
to take advantage of the Yards if you're
a quarterback you've got so much open
space you've got to be able to run
extended play he said the days of Dan
Marino and Peyton Manning are over
what do you make of them
I mean I think it's massively beneficial
if you can move
um I don't think it's I don't think it's
a 100 necessity but I do think that if
you have the ability to it it just makes
life so much more difficult for defenses
I mean not only from a pass rush
standpoint having to try and keep you in
the pocket and then chase you when
you're out of the pocket but when you
can move you extend the place so long
and DB is the heart a cornerback is the
hardest job besides quarterback the guy
who actually hasn't like know
everybody's job but physically the
position of cornerback is the hardest
position to play in the NFL you're not
allowed to touch the guys but you have
to cover them they know where you're
going you don't know where they're going
and it's just the longer you have to do
it the harder it is so any quarterback
that can extend the play with their legs
just allows the receiver to get open and
also the cornerback then has to come up
and make a tackle as well you know for a
quarterback running or running back
running the the devaluing of running
backs
what what advice would you give either
the NFL player association or running
backs as how to improve your financial
lot in life
it's really the tough man I mean it's
it's the best proof so far that business
is the business like we we just that
that is the reality of the situation
some people are beneficiaries of it the
fact that you know contracts are going
up and people are willing to Value
positions higher and some people are on
the other side of it and running backs
right now are on the other side of it
where ownership is kind of seeing that
in their eyes
you can try and find a guy in the draft
and you can try and find a younger guy
and pay pay that guy a whole lot less
and see if you can get by and they're
they're basically what they're trying to
say essentially is that
I can find a running back that's not as
good but as the margin is smaller I
can't do that at Edge I can't do that at
a receiver
um and I mean I've played against a lot
of running backs and there's some
incredible running backs out there that
I believe are worth every single penny
it's just that's the business that the
owners have decided to do and from what
what do you do as a player standpoint
sadly there's really not a whole lot you
can do you go out there and you play as
good as you can possibly play a book we
signed up we're in a CBA like you can't
you can't have a one position group hold
out it doesn't doesn't work sadly
I I noticed the Hat uh Burnley soccer so
you're a part owner of the soccer club
indeed
oh wow my bad I I just don't want you to
get in trouble with the Europeans Dan I
know you're big in your eyes
yeah uh by the way we're going to Dublin
in three weeks
gonna do the show over there
I mean you have an open invite Will Will
Ferrell's going to join us so
I absolutely adore Ireland it is one of
my favorite places in the world Guinness
is the nectar of the Gods and uh I enjoy
it I'm very jealous of you guys okay yes
Burnley I'm going over to Burnley uh
next week my wife and I are going The
Opening match we play Manchester City in
The Opening match on Friday next week
and it's going to be great now how much
is your wife teaching you about soccer
oh come on I've been a big fan for a
long time but she does teach me uh she
does teach me some of the very fine
intricacies of the game obviously we're
watching The Women's World Cup right now
but it's been fascinating our manager
Vincent company is a long time Premier
League Legend and uh he asks me
questions uh about things in the NFL
because he's he's a brilliant mind and
he always wants to learn so he'll ask me
different things about NFL meetings and
schedules to on the field things like I
want to know how how you signal plays
and and what's coverage is like how do
you beat tone coverages how do you beat
man coverages it's fascinating to have
conversation with him good to talk to
you uh I wouldn't go too tight the suit
for CBS
no I gotta breathe it's got to breathe
yeah you just
you want to call attention to your words
not you know your your physique your
arms so no no crazy patterns no crazy
combos no no just clean
just clean and crisp you know you don't
you don't want to be outlandish just
because what you're wearing
right I want my words to be outlined
yeah but no no you don't have to be
outlandish you just have to be
professional
that's what you want to be you want to
be professional like me
absolutely yes not uh yeah you don't how
are the boys are all the boys are all
the boys
let's see Nancy can we take a picture of
uh the Dan etson show JJ you know
and I pretty much
there they are saying yeah yeah
you guys look great you guys look great
I hope everybody's good
I appreciate hope to see you guys in
person again soon
you have a Burnley kit and hat coming
your way fritzy probably stole it and
put it in his house but uh it should be
there soon busted fritzy did something
come in for me from JJ I don't want to
get into it right now
all right uh hey congrats good luck and
uh and we'll hopefully talk again soon
thank you that's JJ have a great day
that's uh three-time NFL Defensive
Player of the Year and uh CBS Sports NFL
studio analyst